[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wird aus einer Krise
ein Krieg die Meldungen von heute aus
berkarabach lassen jedenfalls nichts
Gutes erahnen aber der Reihe nach die
Kaukasus Region Bergkarabach gehört
völkerrechtlich zu Aserbaidschan wird
aber mehrheitlich von Armenien bewohnt
beide Länder streiten sich im Grunde
seitdem Zerfall der Sowjetunion um diese
Enklave und lieferten sich sogar schon
zwei Kriege um dieses Gebiet Anfang der
1990er Jahre und
2020 nachdem also bei Jan monatelang die
einzige Zufahrtsstraße von Armenien in
die Enklave gesperrt und somit eine
massive Versorgungskrise ausgelöst hatte
heute also nun eine militärische
Eskalation angeblich so heißt es um die
verfassungsmäßige Ordnung wieder
herzustellen was ist mit der
Militäroperation die heute früh startete
auf sich hat Sebastian eben
auch als die Sonne schon untergegangen
ist geht der Beschuss weiter ein freier
Journalist veröffentlicht diese Bilder
aus der panna kehrt der Hauptstadt
bergkarabachs seit dem frühen Morgen
wird die von aserbaidschanischen
Streitkräften angegriffen es soll
mindestens 20 Tote und mehr als 100
Verletzte geben darunter auch Zivilisten
wir waren in der Nähe des Hügels als die
Explosionen begannen wir haben es
geschafft zu überleben meine Schwester
und ich haben überlebt
das aserbaidschanische
Verteidigungsministerium hatte am Mittag
den Beginn eines Zitat Anti
terror-einsatzes verkündet man wolle die
militärische Infrastruktur der bergkamin
jetzt zerstören es ist eine Fortsetzung
der Politik des maximalen Drucks
gegenüber den in bergkamerbach lebenden
armenierinnen und Armenien jetzt eben
unter Einsatz militärische Mitteln die
Lage in bergkara Bach gilt seit Monaten
als katastrophal rund 120.000 Menschen
haben nicht genug zu essen die Regale
sind leer denn also bei John blockiert
die einzige Verbindungsstraße zwischen
Armenien und Bergkarabach
Hilfslieferungen kommen kaum noch durch
jetzt ist eben man diesen Punkt
ausgekommen an dem neun Monate
aushungern dann auch dann auch erheblich
an Kräften gezehrt haben so dass einfach
auch die Menschen geschwächt sind wir
sind geschwächt physische sind
geschwächt psychisch und dazu jetzt eben
noch der der Militärschlag oben drauf
der armenische premier Nicole passhinian
spricht von ethnischen Säuberungen und
wirft als Aserbaidschan vor Armenien in
einen Krieg ziehen zu wollen doch
Pasching Jan betont Armenien werde
militärischen nicht einschreiten dagegen
protestieren in der Hauptstadt jerevan
hunderte für sie ist klar bergkara Bach
darf nicht aufgegeben werden wie es für
die Menschen dort jetzt weitergeht
unklar
wir können davon ausgehen dass in jedem
Haushalt Waffen sind dass die Menschen
im Kampf erprobt sind und dass sie hier
möglicherweise in einer Art geringer
Kampf eintreten und das noch sehr viel
länger eine unruhige Region bleiben wird
also bei Joan erklärte unterdessen man
werde den Militäreinsatz erst beenden
wenn die armenische Führungen
und das alles gerade mal vier
Flugstunden von uns entfernt schalten
wir zu Armin Körper der für uns in
Moskau ist und vor drei Jahren in der
Region war um über den letzten Krieg
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern so
berichten Armin was ist denn das Ziel
aktuell von Aserbaidschan
also von armenischer Seite wird gesagt
dass Arbeit Aserbaidschan ein klares
Ziel verfolgt die Vertreibung der
armenischen Bevölkerung aus Bergkarabach
und somit einen Exodus herbeizurufen man
muss aber dazu spricht dafür spricht
Entschuldigung dafür spricht dass wir
heute davon gehört haben dass
Flugblätter abgebrochen wurden und die
Bevölkerung aufgerufen wurde
Bergkarabach zu verlassen das deutet
also darauf hin gleichzeitig muss man
bei diesem Konflikt der ja zu den
ältesten der Welt zählt und zu den
Gründungszeiten der Sowjetunion
zurückführt da muss man sehen dass immer
in diesem Konflikt zwei militärische
Schwergewichte im Hintergrund stehen und
das sind Russland und die Türkei
Armenien allein hat ja diesen Angriffen
jetzt wenig entgegenzusetzen was ist
denn mit dessen Schutz macht Russland
also seit dem Waffenstillstand von vor
drei Jahren gibt es doch sogar eine
russische Friedenstruppe dort
genau die gibt es und die
schutzmachtfunktion Russlands geht
zurück auf 1995 als ein Militärabkommen
zwischen Armenien und Russland
unterzeichnet wurde gleichzeitig muss
man wenn man sich die Ereignisse der
letzten Wochen und Monate mal genauer
anschaut feststellen dass vieles auf
eine Eskalation hindeutet als nämlich
Aserbaidschan berkarabach abgeriegelt
hat und eine humanitäre Katastrophe
hervorgerufen hat da haben die
russischen friedenstruppentatenlos
zugeschaut das zeigt das Russland im
aktuellen Konflikt um die Ukraine viel
mehr Interesse an Kontakten zur
aserbaidschan hat was rohstoffreich ist
was geostrategisch interessanter gelegen
ist für Russland und natürlich hat
Russland ein großes Interesse an den
Beziehungen zur Türkei die ja im Ukraine
Konflikt an der Vermittlerrolle
eingenommen hat darauf hat Armenien auch
bromt reagiert hat Hilfslieferung in die
Ukraine geschickt hat mir sogar
Militärmanöver mit den USA durchgeführt
das hat man hier hinter mir family
überhaupt nicht gerne gesehen und das
zeigt dass mit Russland der Türkei und
auch den USA großmächtig in diesem
Konflikt verwickelt sind es ist last but
not least auch kein Zufall dass das
jetzt passiert nach dem vor drei Wochen
die Herren Putin und Erdogan im
russischen Sotschi auch über berg-rabach
verhandelt haben das heißt alles was
hier passiert steht in einem
geopolitischen Zusammenhang und es
deutet sich an oder man kann heute abend
vorhersehen dass sich die
Kräfteverhältnisse in Osteuropa
verschieben könnten und das auf dem
Rücken der Zivilbevölkerung an den
Körper vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
ja und Frankreich strebt wegen dieser
Ereignisse in Bergkarabach eine
Dringlichkeitssitzung des
UN-Sicherheitsrates an zuvor hatte
Armenien den Sicherheitsrat aber auch
Russland aufgefordert Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um diesen Militäreinsatz zu
beenden gemeint ist natürlich der von
Aserbaidschan und nicht der der Russen
die ihren Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine offiziell ja auch als
Militäroperation deklarieren wie gut das
alle Betroffenen aktuell zur Zeit in New
York beisammen sind und auf offener
Weltbühne aber ja auch hinter
verschlossenen Türen miteinander ins
Gespräch kommen können wenn sie denn
wollen einer wird diese Bühne ganz
sicher Nutzen aus New York wissen
als er heute kommt da halt noch nach was
wo wurde mir selenski vorher im
US-Fernsehsender CBS sagte emrace einen
zweiten hitler hat die russische
Gesellschaft erschaffen wir können die
Zeit nicht zurückdrehen aber wir können
es hier stoppen stapelt hier das würden
sie zwar gerne aber allzu heftige
Verbalattacken empfinden viele nicht als
hilfreich schließlich will man auch jene
überzeugen die wie der Präsident
Brasiliens glauben dass die
Waffenlieferungen an Kiew den Krieg doch
nur befeuert auch deshalb redet der
UN-Generalsekretär erstmal allen ins
Gewissen
autorinsen isomat Autoritarismus ist auf
dem Vormarsch Ungleichheiten wachsen
Hassreden verschärfen sich trotz dieser
Herausforderungen ist Kompromiss zu
einem schmutzigen Wort geworden
unsere Welt braucht Staatskunst keine
Spielchen keinen Stillstand
es folgt ein leidenschaftlicher manchmal
wütender Appell von Lola da Silva die
Welt dürfen nicht den Einfluss Sphären
geteilt und in einen neuen Kalten Krieg
gestürzt werden
unsere kollektive Unfähigkeit die Ziele
und Prinzipien der un-kata durchzusetzen
wir unterschätzen nicht die
Schwierigkeiten Frieden zu erreichen
aber keine Lösung wird belastbar sein
ohne Dialog
für noch furchtbar werden
Joe Biden kommt zu spät um Lula
zuzuhören Russland sagt er rechne damit
dass die Welt müde werde und Putin
weiter Krieg führen lasse
Prinzipien der Vereinten Nationen
aufgeben um einen Aggressor zu
beschwichtigen kann irgendein
Mitgliedstaat sicher sein dass er
geschützt ist wenn wir die Aufteilung
der Ukraine zulassen ist dann die
Unabhängigkeit irgendeiner Nation
gesichert
genau dies ist auch sein stärkstes
Argument keine Beschimpfungen sondern
eine glühende Anklage gegen das Land
dass die Regel basierte Ordnung ja die
Welt zerstören wolle
der Gresser ist Rapper der Aggressor
verwandelt viele Dinge in Waffen und
richtet diese dann nicht nur gegen unser
Land sondern auch gegen ihre Länder
Russland benutzt die nahrungspreise als
Waffen der Aggressor verbreitet tot und
schafft Ruinen ohne Nuklearwaffen aber
mit dem gleichen Ergebnis
bitte hört mich an lasst uns gemeinsam
und offen darüber entscheiden während
Russland die Welt in einen großen
Endkampf drängt versucht die Ukraine
alles um sicherzustellen dass es künftig
niemand mehr wagt irgendeine Nation
anzugreifen
im Weltsicherheitsrat morgen willenski
neue friedensvorschläge machen seine
Rede halten nach ob sie wirkt bleibt
offen
der ukrainische Präsident der ja schon
bei anderen Gipfeln dabei war G7 NATO EU
ist also erstmals seit Beginn des
Krieges bei der unvollversammlung vor
Ort dabei hier wird er dann auch
versuchen die skeptischen oder
zögerlichen Länder von seinem Kurs zu
überzeugen denn insbesondere der globale
Süden der pocht ja auf eine Deeskalation
des Krieges und der geht auch an Tag 573
unvermindert weiter was ist für eine
erfolgreiche Gegenoffensive braucht
neben Waffen und Munition ist Geduld wie
Henna hier bestreit berichtet
die Gegenoffensive der ukrainischen
Truppen südlich von saporicia kommt nur
schleppend voran sobald sie eine Salbe
abgefeuert haben verstecken sie ihre
Geschütze warten im Bunker auf eine
Reaktion
es ist nicht leicht jeder Zentimeter
jedes Feld jeder Busch überall lauern
sie auf dich
unsere Soldaten müssen dahin um
sicherzustellen dass da niemand mehr ist
außer unseren Jungs
muss sie mit allem versorgen was die
Truppe braucht Russland umeroff Anfang
des monatsübernahme mitten im Krieg den
Job des Verteidigungsministers
meine Verantwortung als
Verteidigungsminister ist es alles
Mögliche und Unmögliche zu tun damit
unsere Kämpfer mit allem ausgestattet
sind was Sie brauchen
der 41-Jährige gilt in der Ukraine als
effizienter Manager dem auch zugetraut
wird die Korruption in
Verteidigungsbereich zu bekämpfen
[Musik]
loszuwerden müssen wir die korrupten
Leute in der Spitze des Ministeriums
loswerden wer bei ordentlicher und
effektiver Beschaffung in
Verteidigungssektor versagt hat muss so
schnell wie möglich gefeuert werden
diesen Forderungen ist der neue Minister
rechtzeitig zu den Rammstein Gesprächen
nachgekommen dass die gesamte Spitze
seines Ministeriums musste gehen
betroffen davon auch seine prominente
Vertreterin Hanna
auch neue Partner suchen
er spricht auch fließend Türkisch und er
ist Muslim er stammt ab von den Krim
Tataren das heißt er weiß wie der Osten
tickt wie die arabisch muslimische Welt
arbeitet
erstmal will er aber für seine Soldaten
an der Front um noch mehr Ausrüstung bei
den Verbündeten der Ukraine in der NATO
bitten
es ist unsere Hauptaufgabe eine
Vereinbarung mit den Partnern zu
schaffen um die Waffen auf das
Schlachtfeld zu liefern damit Sie so
schnell wie möglich dort eintreffen
es dürfte ihm auch um Taurus
Marschflugkörper gehen damit seine
Soldaten mehr Ziele angreifen können
ohne eine sofortige Reaktion der Russen
befürchten zu müssen
ja und Taurus Marschflugkörper
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz erklärt
die können hunderte Kilometer weit
fliegen und dann zum Beispiel Bunker
Munitionsdepots oder andere gut
gesicherte Anlagen zerstören und genau
das macht das Waffensystem für die
Ukraine so wertvoll das Land wird sich
aber weiter gedulden müssen denn auch
bei mittlerweile fünften Treffen der
sogenannten Ukraine Kontaktgruppe auf
dem
US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt Rammstein gab es
in Sachen Taurus keine Zusage ganz leer
geht die Ukraine aber nicht aus bereits
im Vorfeld hatte der aufgrund einer
Erkrankung nicht in persona teilnehmende
deutsche Verteidigungsminister er
bereits neue rüstungshilfen angekündigt
und auch
US-Verteidigungsminister aus den liefert
und zwar
us-kampfpanzer die sollen nun bald in
der Ukraine ankommen
florian neuhahn hat das Treffen ranghuan
militärs- und Verteidigungsminister aus
zahlreichen Ländern für uns verfolgt
Florian worum ist es bei dem Treffen
denn dann vorrangig gegangen also
Geschlossenheit zu demonstrieren und was
noch
erstmal kann ich sagen worum es nicht
gegen das waren die berühmten Taurus
Marschflugkörper über die wurde offenbar
gar nicht gesprochen wie ich höre das
zeigt auch dass die deutsche Debatte der
offenbar mal wieder zu sehr verengt ist
davon einziges Waffensystem tatsächlich
liegt der größte Bedarf der Ukraine
aktuell mal wieder bei der Luft Abwehr
da gab es offenbar wirklich
eindringliche Appelle des
US-amerikanischen Verteidigungsministers
Leute Austin der alle Staaten des
Westens aufforderte noch mal ihre Lager
zu durchforsten ob irgendwo ein
Luftabwehrsystem noch entbehrlich ist um
die Ukraine besser gegen russische
Luftangriffe zu schützen aber aus den
hatte eben auch eine Mahnung dabei für
die Ukraine selbst er sagte die USA
würden sehr genau überprüfen wie die
gelieferten Waffen genutzt werden und
das deutete ich als Erinnerung an diese
Zusage der Ukraine die gelieferten
Waffen nicht für Angriffe auf russisches
Gebiet zu verwenden und da wiederum
schließt sich der Kreis denn genau das
ist ja die große Sorge die auch die
deutsche Bundesregierung derzeit noch
bei dem Taurus Raketen bremst also wenn
es gelingen sollte diese Sorge hier
politisch oder auch technisch zu lösen
dann wäre der Weg auch für die Taurus
Raketen frei und das könnte schon in den
nächsten Tagen passieren sagt Florian
neuhahn vielen Dank für die Beobachtung
und Einschätzung
und hier geht es jetzt erstmal weiter
mit dem ersten Nachrichtenblock von
Gundula und der beginnt mit Vorwürfen
zum ersten Mal gibt es
Missbrauchsvorwürfe gegen einen
deutschen Kardinal persönlich der 1991
verstorbenen Bischof von Essen Franz
Hengsbach soll Minderjährige sexuell
missbraucht haben das Bistum Essen
erklärte heute gravierende Vorwürfe
würden geprüft die drei betreffenden
Fälle sollen sich in den 1950er und 60er
Jahren ereignet haben der jüngste wurde
erst vor einem Jahr angezeigt frühere
Vorwürfe wurden auch von Rom aus als
nicht plausibel abgewiesen Kardinal
Franz Hengsbach war Gründer Bischof des
Bistums
Essens Deutschland verboten und 700
Einsatzkräfte durchsuchten bei einer
bundesweiten
solchen Führungsfiguren und
beschlagnahmten Bargeld Waffen und
ns-130 Mitglieder zählende Gruppe sei so
dass Innenministerium in der
rechtsextremistischen Musikszene aktiv
und agiere international
die Debatte über den Umgang mit der
Migration hält an CDU-Chef Merz sprach
sich wie zuvor schon CSU-Chef Söder für
eine Aufnahme Obergrenze von 200.000
Menschen pro Jahr als Orientierungsgröße
aus grünen Fraktionschefin dröge warnte
die Union vor einem
Überbietungswettbewerb die
Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Alaba von der SPD
betonte es könne keine
nationalstaatlichen Lösungen geben
migrationsabkommen müssten verhandelt
und geflüchtete solidarisch in Europa
verteilt werden
die Zahl der Ausweisungen ausländischer
Straftäter aus Deutschland ist
rückläufig das berichtet die Zeitung
Welt aus einer Antwort der
Bundesregierung auf einer Anfrage der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
2021 gab es demnach noch
11.599 Ausweisungen im vergangenen Jahr
dann noch 10.000 45 und bis Ende August
diesen Jahres
Ausweisungen ein Teil der ausgewiesenen
Straftäter halte sich außerdem
inzwischen wieder in Deutschland auf
das Thema Migration ist in den letzten
Tagen wieder sehr präsent in der
politischen Debatte in den Medien am
Stammtisch oder aber auch in den
sozialen Medien oft werden da diverse
Dinge in einen Topf geworfen die
eigentlich gar nicht zusammengehören
beispielsweise der Schutz von
Asylsuchenden und gesteuerte Zuwanderung
wie auch immer eine der wichtigsten
Fragen ganz grundsätzlich ist ja wer
soll kommen bzw wer darf bleiben auch um
den Fachkräftemangel zu beheben und den
demografischen Wandel abzufedern umso
unverständlicher ist das was ich gerade
in und vor Ausländerbehörden abspielt
Sven Klasse über die Situation in
Stuttgart die seit Wochen nicht gelöst
werden kann sehr zum Leidwesen
derjenigen die gebraucht werden und
zurück zur Arbeit wollen und für so ein
Chaos schlicht gar keine Zeit haben
die ganze Nacht und länger haben viele
hier verbracht um endlich ganz vorne in
der Schlange anzukommen
jetzt bin ich erst mal fertig
nein wo bist du denn ich warte hier
bitte die wenigen Einlasskarten noch vor
der Öffnung des Ausländeramts in
Stuttgart wirst mal vergriffen von mehr
als 24 Stunden ausharren berichten
manche viele versuchen es nicht zum
ersten Mal
am Mittwoch waren wir da
am Freitag waren wir da kein Termin
gekriegt ein E-Mail hatte ich schon vor
einem Monat geschrieben fünf Tage
nachdem ich mein Studium angeschlossen
habe und seitdem warte ich auf Antwort
aber es kann also geht gar nicht und
Telefonate sind auch erfolglos ich habe
jetzt gemacht im Krankenhaus Schwester
kommen auch hier stehen und auch bin ich
sicher wenn ich dann rein darf und
wahrscheinlich muss ich selbst morgen um
3 Uhr kommen ich verstehe nicht die
Probleme ist bekannt das ist nicht von
gestern das dauert schon eine lange Zeit
und gibt keine Lösung Ausländerbehörden
Stellen zum Beispiel Dokumente für
Flüchtlinge aus aber auch arbeitswieser
für EU-Bürger bundesweit sind viele
dieser Ämter massiv überlastet hier in
Stuttgart sagen viele sei es besonders
schlimm mehr Personal soll die Probleme
demnächst zumindest lindern wir haben
knapp 30 Prozent unbesetzte Stellen dann
kommt noch Urlaub und Krankheit
obendrauf das bedeutet wenn Sie sich
vorstellen von zehn Schreibtischen sind
drei nicht besetzt aber es liegen
trotzdem Akten drauf und stapeln sich
dass wir eine erhebliche buchwelle vor
uns herschieben das hier ist dabei nur
die notfallschlange besonders dringende
Fälle etwa weil das Visum in den
nächsten Tagen abläuft der sichtbare
Teil der Überforderung der nach außen un
sichtbare fast 30.000 unbearbeitete
E-Mails viele der Betroffenen Fachkräfte
die zum Beispiel hier dringend benötigt
werden der Operationsbereich oder die
Intensivstation wo wir im großen
Fachkräftemangel haben da kommt es auf
jede einzelne Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter an wenn die fehlen müssen
wir betten sperren Operationen aus wir
haben jetzt in der letzten Zeit einige
Mitarbeiter deshalb weil wir einfach
nicht mehr die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung
hatten auch andere Branchen schlagen
Alarm sehen aber nicht nur die Kommunen
in der Pflicht es gibt eine hohe
zweistellige Anzahl von
unterschiedlichen Verfahrensarten man
braucht nahezu ein Studium um überhaupt
diese Verfahren zu verstehen da ist der
Gesetzgeber der Bundesgesetzgeber
gefordert diese Verfahren zu
vereinfachen man arbeite bereits an
rechtlichen Vereinfachungen heißt es
dazu aus dem Innenministerium
entsprechende Schritte sind im Beschluss
zu Besprechung des Bundeskanzlers mit
den Regierungschefs der Länder vom 10
Mai festgehalten und wurden durch die
Bundesregierung auch umgesetzt bzw
finden sich in Umsetzung die Überlastung
von Ausländerbehörden betrachte man mit
Sorge bei vielen die hier in der
Schlange stehen ist es mehr als das es
geht schlich darum wie ihr Leben
weitergeht
und wir machen jetzt hier erstmal weiter
mit dem Blick auf und in die Wirtschaft
und mit dem Bösen Wort das mit i beginnt
auch genau die hohe Inflation und die
unsichere Entwicklung in China bleiben
Risikofaktoren für die Weltwirtschaft so
sieht es die
industriestaatenorganisation OECD in
ihrem aktuellen Konjunkturausblick Frank
beetmann an der Börse und deutschland
schneidet in der Prognose besonders
schlecht ab ja das ist so nur für einen
Industriestaat sieht es noch drüber aus
als für Deutschland und da reden wir
über Argentinien ein Land ohne Schulden
geplagten auf internationale
Finanzhilfen angewiesen also das sollte
eigentlich nicht der Maßstab für die
heimische Wirtschaft sein die OECD
prognostiziert dass die deutsche
Wirtschaft in diesem Jahr um 0,2%
schrumpft dann in 20 24 wieder um 0,9%
wächst doch erst verglichen mit der
globalen Wirtschaftsleistung wird
deutlich wie sehr Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit Zeit auseinanderklaffen mit
ihrem neuesten Ausblick auf das Jahr
2024 ist die OECD sogar noch
pessimistischer als die EU-Kommission
oder einige führende deutsche
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute die
OECD-Experten gehen mir aber auch immer
Ratschläge welche Wege aus der Krise
empfehlen sie ja sie machen der
deutschen Wirtschaft trotz allem Mut
Deutschland habe immer noch ziemlich
große Stärken zum Beispiel die
hochqualifizierten Arbeitskräfte das
Land sei aber auch nach wie vor reich
und könne insgesamt vier Kapital
mobilisieren und damit die Konjunktur
wieder ankurbeln aber Deutschland müsste
auch Reformen angehen auf eine
Baustellen gebe es reichlich von der
Digitalisierung bis zum Fachkräftemangel
so wäre ein Ansatz die
arbeitsmarktbeteiligung von Frauen
älteren Menschen sowie gering
Qualifizierten zu verbessern
Bürokratie abbauen danke Frank Widmann
an die Börse wir haben ein
fußballergebnis vom Abend RB Leipzig hat
als erster Bundesligist die neue Saison
in der Champions League eröffnet und zum
Auftakt die Young Boys Bern besiegt die
Schweizer Unterlagen 1 zu 3 bei der
Versorgung von Bewohnern in deutschen
Pflegeheimen gibt es starke regionale
Qualitätsunterschiede dem Pflegereport
der AOK zufolge bekommen in einigen
Regionen mindestens 10% der
Pflegeheimbewohner dauerhaft Schlaf und
Beruhigungsmittel verabreicht besonders
häufig im Saarland und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen vorsichtiger werden
ruhigstellende Medikamente in
Ostdeutschland eingesetzt
wer Polarlichter mit eigenen Augen sehen
will der reißt normalerweise in den
hohen Norden oder ganz weit Richtung
Süden gestern aber hat schon eine Fahrt
nach Magdeburg gereicht um sie am
Nachthimmel Strahlen zu sehen ein
schillerndes buntes leuchten wie auf
Island oder in der Antarktis tausende
Kilometer von Nord und Südpol entfernt
sind Polarlichter äußerst selten zu
sehen
einer der wie es heißt die Kabine in
Bayern verloren hat und wohl unter
anderem auch deshalb den FCB verlassen
musste wird möglicherweise neuer
Bundestrainer wo er wieder auf die
trifft die er in der Kabine verloren hat
alle Fußballfans wissen natürlich sofort
von wem ich rede es geht um Julian
nagelsmann freigestellter Coach der
Bayern 36 Jahre jung und er soll die
deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft in
der ja eben auch viele Bayern-Spieler
sind übernehmen ob er sich damit
übernimmt wird sich auf dem Platz und in
der Kabine zeigen heute gab es
jedenfalls ein Treffen zwischen dem DFB
und Julian nagelsmann
der Wunschkandidat soll es nun auch
werden Julian nagelsmann eine der
namhaftesten deutschen Fußballtrainer
auf dem freien Markt soll laut
Fachmagazin Kicker eine mündliche
Einigung mit dem Deutschen Fußball-Bund
erzielt haben dem ZDF bestätigt der
Verband das DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf und Rudi Völler nagelsmann
getroffen haben und mit ihm in guten
Gesprächen sind so würde der FC Bayern
mehr und mehr zur trainerschmiede des
DFB und offenbar wie schon bei Hansi
Flick keine Ablösezahlung vom finanziell
klammen DFB für Julian nagelsmann
verlangen vor zwei Jahren noch zahlte
der FC Bayern geschätzt 20 Millionen
Euro an RB Leipzig nagelsmann treffe mit
dem großen bayernblock im Nationalteam
auf bekannte Gesichter und wäre mit 36
Jahren der zweitjüngste DFB Cheftrainer
jemals nur Orts war 1926 junge für
Liverpool Coach Jürgen Klopp kein Thema
Alter komplett egal er hat schon mit 28
bewiesen dass er ein fantastischer
Trainer ist er hat acht Jahre Erfahrung
das haben andere mit 45 oder 50 auf
höchstem Niveau ich würde mich sehr
darüber freuen wenn es denn so kommt
auch nagelsmanns Nachfolger beim FC
Bayern voll des Lobes julian hat sein
Qualität und der DFB hat sich dafür
entschieden und er hat sich dafür
entschieden und damit ist die wichtigste
Voraussetzung gegeben es gibt eine
Entscheidung noch ist nichts
unterschrieben Gehalt und
Vertragslaufzeit Verhandlungssache
sollten sich nagelsmann die dfb-führung
und die Bayern einigen müssen noch
dfb-aufsichtsrat und Präsidium zustimmen
dann tippe ich mal auf Freitag da
treffen sich nämlich alle
und in unserem heute journal Update um
00:30 Uhr spricht Nazan Göttin mir mit
der Präsidentin des Deutschen
pflegerrates über die Pflegesituation in
Deutschland und jetzt folgt ein
sympathischer Familienvater der ein
seltsames Hobby hat was seine Frau alles
andere als lustig findet jetzt bei den
Kollegen von 37 Grad tschüss schönen
Abend noch bis morgen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter mit
diesem Sonnenaufgang begann der Tag
heute in der Kieler Förde es war ein
stürmischer Tag hier denn es nähert sich
uns jetzt dieses Tief hier das hat sich
übrigens aus einem ehemaligen Hurrikan
Lee entwickelt das sorgt eben für mehr
Wind und es sorgt auch für diese richtig
sommerlichen Temperaturen die da in den
nächsten Tagen noch einmal auf uns
zukommen zunächst aber zu der Nacht da
bleibt es im Norden weiter stürmisch
hier auch noch mehr Wolken und
gebietsweise etwas Regen Richtung Süden
ist der Himmel aber immer öfter klar
ganz im Süden bildet sich Nebel da
sinken die Temperaturen morgen früh dann
auch auf 7 Grad unter den Wolken bleibt
deutlich milder bei 17 Grad an der
Nordsee und auf der Nordsee sind auch
morgen stürmische Böden möglich generell
im Nordwesten weiter ein frischer
Südwestwind sonst ist der Wind aber
schwächer als noch heute im Nordwesten
da finden wir auch anfangs noch dichtere
Wolken noch Schauer an der See
nachmittags schaut hier die Sonne dann
immer öfter raus ein freundlicher
Tagesstart wird es im Südosten nach
Auflösung der Nebelfelder und daneben
diese Temperaturen 21 Grad gibt es in
Schleswig-Holstein 25 Grad und mehr als
einen Sommertag erreichen wir im Osten
und im Südwesten des Landes der
Donnerstag legt dann noch einmal eine
Schippe drauf vor allem mit Brandenburg
und Sachsen-Anhalt mit Temperaturen bis
29 Grad dann kommen aber Gewitter und
Schauer von Westen und es wird doch
etwas kühler und eher früh herbstlicher
und damit auf Wiedersehen